hi everyone I'm Silva back in 2007 I was
finishing my PhD in Paris in the tower
INRIA team in the university of paris
out and now I'm part of the Google brain
team in Zurich Switzerland and I'm David
back in 2007 I was doing my PhD at the
University of Alberta and now in 2017
I'm at deep mind I'm really sorry we
can't be there a person that we prepared
this presentation and I hope that makes
up right we are going to take you in a
journey and a very specific type of
journey a trying travel so we're going
from 2017 to 2007 and then there we are
going to show you how techniques from
reinforcement learning and Monte Carlo
tree search could be used and combined
to improve the computer go
state-of-the-art and then we are going
to show you how over the year those
techniques have evolved up to alphago
with in addition the use of deep
learning even though we are going to
focus on on computer goal as it was the
main application other improvements have
led to applications on games but also
beyond games and now close your eyes and
imagine you are in 2007 of course in
addition to all being 10 years younger
there have been significant differences
one is that deep learning was not yet
rebranded was not reinvented of course
people were using your networks at that
time but it was much less mainstream and
much less used and also less powerful
the also other reinforcement learning
event oh there have been a lot of
success but success was not so taken
seriously and not so used in many places
and was not considered at something you
could just take and use for your
application and in the specific case of
computer go the level of traditional
programs at that time was just barely at
the beginner level and using techniques
like elevator search which was the state
of the art
so if we think about artificial
intelligence as a whole there's one
fundamental problem which is at the
heart of it and that's the question of
how do you get an agent to achieve a
goal and planning really focuses on this
problem it says that if you're given the
rules if you're given a model of the
dynamics or of the transitions in your
problem how do you pick a sequence of
actions so to achieve that goal and so
really this is the fundamental question
of AI and computer go became intercept
Allah for this particular planning
problem in other words it's the testbed
but many people focused on and many
people viewed it as a grand challenge
the planning and the litmus test to show
that if we really made progress in this
domain that we really would have made
some significant strides towards many
other kinds of climbing problems so go
in particular is nicest because it has
very simple rules in other words this
model that we know it is very
straightforward and it can be simulated
very efficiently and effectively and
also we have a nice way to test our
performance by simply playing games
against humans and seeing how well our
programs actually perform in practice so
if we compare go to something like
checkers or chess domains where
traditional search have been very
effective we see there was a big
difference then for those domains there
was a more limited branching factor and
a more limited depth leading to a more
manageable search tree so if we think
about the game of chess for example
there's a branching factor of around 40
in each position about 40 different
legal moves that can be taken and the
game lasts for around 80 different steps
over the course of the game and in
particular is also possible to make
quite a simple straightforward
evaluation of a position by simply
adding up the piece values for black and
white and that already gives you a very
simple indication of who's actually
winning in that position if we contrast
that to the game of Go we see that in go
there's something more like a few
hundred possible actions in each
position and the game lasts for several
hundred different steps throughout the
game and as a result the branching
factor becomes absolutely enormous and
on top of that there's this fundamental
problem of how to evaluate a position so
in the game of go each position has some
scattering of black and white stones you
have to predict from that position where
we typically have the same number of
black stones as white stones who is
going to win in the game and this became
a large and unsolved problem which led
to many
the techniques we'll talk about today
including Monte Carlo search and deep
learning approaches so if we look at
progress in computer go before 2007 we
see these traditional search approach
approaches based on algorithms like
alpha beta search but somehow stalled
they've reached this kind of beginner
level which is known as a mature Q level
in the game of Go and then it somehow
stalled at roughly this beginner level
and was not able to really scale up in
this very large in challenging search
space so now how do you find a good
action for given position so one
approach one dimension of the approach
is to take decision online which means
that given the position given the state
you are going to spend your compute
resources at that state to compute the
best action for that particular state
and that that's the advantage that you
don't need to solve the wall program you
just need to focus and find a good
action for this particular position and
so that means it's a local search and we
are going to focus ourselves to a
particular way to do that using when you
have a model you can do planning or
search and of course you can use alpha
beta with evolution function like in
chess or like in the column in the
traditional computer Go programs but
here we are focusing on sampled planning
so the simplest way to do some pro
standing how would you do it is let's
say you start with the position here and
you want to compute its online value a V
of X and what you can do is given a roll
out policy and we are going to see later
how you could build that but assume we
have some roll out policy you could use
this policy to play against itself up to
the end of the game several times and
once you are at the end of the game what
you can do is just count which side is
winning so now you get the outcome from
there and with Monte Carlo the simple
thing you'd say is that the online value
you get is simply the average of the
outcomes divided by how many times you
tried and as you do more simulations you
reduce the variance of this estimate and
it converts to the expected value of the
roll out policy playing against itself
but you have to remember here that the
stroller policy in this case is fixed
which means that even with infinite
compute power
you're not going to converge to the
minimax value so now how could you
improve that beyond that and that's the
idea that came on multicolored research
the idea is to say if I going to spend
more compute time shouldn't I just
improve the policy iteratively and one
way to improve the policy is to build a
search tree and remember their online
value so that you can use it to improve
and now the policy will have two parts
one which is inside the tree and this
one will improve over time and the other
which is the same rollout policy as
we've seen in Monte Carlo
so this deep diving into a concrete
example so it's a you have this position
you can at the first iteration you're
going to just use like in Monte Carlo
the rollout policy up to the end and get
the outcome and just keep it which means
like the value at this node is one over
one but now contrary to Monte Carlo when
you do the second trial you're going to
expand your tree and remember not only
one value at the root node but now to
online values that is going to keep the
the outcome the average outcome of the
nodes be below that so here when you
expand the trees let's say you try the
right hand side move you're going to use
your rollout policy up to the end and in
that case you get zero so these not get
online value of zero over one but these
node the roots keep the value of the
previous one and so now you have one
over two and you keep extending that
let's say twice and now you have like
these four nodes in your in your tree
and at each node you keep different
value which corresponds to the average
outcome of the nodes below that and now
the question is what do you do with this
value and how do you expand so one idea
is you see T which stands for upper
confidence bound for tree where you are
going to see how you explore how you
change your policy to exploratory so
let's take the simplest idea let's say
you have this tree for each node you
have the online value computed so far
and one idea to say if I want to choose
which action to explore next I'm just
going to take the one that has the
highest current value so the highest
average which will be this bus and
you're going to try from this node to
see what's next and that would be using
the the best online value but you can
see that if you were to choose the
right-hand side note so far you did zero
reward out of two trials but what if you
are just unlucky that these were
actually wins but you got unlucky
because there is randomness after or
what if this side was lucky so you need
in addition another term and that's what
this term will play so just to explain a
little bit the notations here we talked
about the value for state and an action
and these terms the end of Si is saying
how many times did you try the action a
in state s and NS is increase the sum of
of NSA for all actions which is the
number of times you visited this state
and you can see that this terms if you
did not try a given action in a state
very often this term will be big so we
will be encouraged to try this action
more likely and this term will try to we
will go to infinity which means that you
will always try all all I visit all
state infinitely many times and the nice
thing with this algorithm is that under
some condition it converges the minimax
program at the limit of compute but now
something to be said is that here you
assume that at the limit you can observe
all state and all action infinitely many
times which of course in practice is
completely impossible so even though
with this exploration term you can
explore every thing you can't really do
that in practice so you have to have
other techniques and we are going to
show that later and actually with the
techniques we are going to show just an
anecdote is at at some point the Mogul
program was having a C constant of 0
which actually remove this step
but ok so now that you have this
algorithm one question is how do you
what what are the limit so one limit is
that because you build the search tree
and in the sub tree you keep the value
as the tab you love function you does no
generalization which means that what you
compute on a given position will have no
effect on what you compute another
position so you don't generalize and the
other thing which means that if you do
not observe this position in your tree
yet then you have no knowledge and
finally for each multicolor in the
variation you just get whether you win
or lose which is very high variance
estimates as we've seen so you need mini
exploration before you get any precise
estimate so one idea we introduced is to
us this Rapid Action value estimate and
what is the idea is to say let's say you
have these the search tree and here are
the simulation out of the tree and you
want to compute the online value of t3
and you see that from this node you pay
3 3 only one and you are the knot cannot
0 so the value as we explained before is
0 over 1 but you did you also try other
move here and you did place III later in
the game so you add some information and
the simple idea here is to say maybe I
can look at the other game so I play C 3
and then as a satellite teammate of how
good this tree so if a game where place
the tree is a win maybe C 3 has some
value if your game playing C 3 as a loss
maybe it's not so good and so in that
particular case you see that you place C
3 actually five times and you want three
times so the rave value of C 3 is 3 over
5 and again you can do that on all nodes
and so for this node you pay C 3 three
times and only once as the next move to
the multicolor value of this move is 1
over 1 and the right value of C 3 is 2
over 3
so I'm now going to talk about a very
different kind of knowledge which we
used in back in 2007 which is the second
idea the idea of offline knowledge and
so this is another type of knowledge and
typically we can think of these as like
predictions that are estimated offline
we're going to talk about two particular
kinds of prediction the value function
and the policy and what's different
about these is that these are now global
to all states because we're learning
offline we don't actually know which
states you'll encounter when you
actually play the game online and so we
need to approximate every possible state
you might encounter which in the game of
Go might be 10 to the hundred and 70
states and we're going to come up with
some kind of estimate of this entire
space and ideally we would like to
estimate these quantities by
reinforcement learning methods although
it's also possible to use other
techniques such as supervised learning
or even hand crafting so we can think of
this as the more familiar technique
nowadays with machine learning but it's
really we should note that this is in
direct contrast to the kind of knowledge
that Silvan was just talking about that
computed online within the search tree
so back then in 2007 we didn't have such
knowledge of convolutional networks and
so forth they were around but they
hadn't been proven to be quite so
effective so we tried something more
naive which was to look at these what we
call shape features which were three by
three patterns which basically indicated
whether a particular pattern was matched
in some location of the board so for
example did this particular pattern of
black and white stones occur here if it
did this particular feature would have a
value of 1 and if it did not occur it
would have a value of 0 and this gave us
a very large binary feature vector
containing about a million different
elements and we estimate the value by
taking a linear combination of all of
the patterns which are present in this
position with some weights and that
gives us our estimate of who is going to
win in this position whether it's going
to be black winning or white winning
just based on these particular patterns
that are occurring and these weights can
be trained by self play reinforcement
learning and so what we tried was using
temporal difference learning so the TD
lambda algorithm to train the weight of
this function approximator and figure
out an effective value function to
estimate who is going to win from each
of these positions and we also had some
handcrafted knowledge to compare to
and so once we actually have this
knowledge we can insert it into the
search tree so we can combine this
offline value function that we figured
out by offline reinforcement learning
with the kind of knowledge that Sylvan
was just talking about this online
values that were computed from the Monte
Carlo simulations and so in particular
the way that we do that that we tried
back in 2007 was we tried to initialize
the node with the value which was
computed offline so instead of just
starting when you create this new node
so imagine this is a node that visited
for the first time so previously we
would have just initialized that note to
say well we haven't visited this anytime
so it's got a visit count of zero and
we've got no idea what the value is yet
so perhaps we assign it a value of zero
and instead of that what we do is we now
initialize those values using our
offline value function as our estimate
of who's going to win and using some
estimate of how much we trust that
offline value which we use to initialize
the count so we can think of this as
some kind of prior knowledge so in
particular it takes the fall of a beta
prior and actually when we initialize
this is a bit like saying if our value
function was 0.3 and we've got and we've
got a count of 10 that's like saying
it's just as if I'd seen 3 wins out of
10 I'm going to trust this offline value
as much as I would have trusted seeing
10 online simulations and computing a
value online from those 10 simulations
and this idea was very effective and
became one of the core ideas that was
used in in mojo and subsequent programs
another idea that we tried and was
actually training a different form of
online knowledge of offline knowledge
this was the offline policy so instead
of training a value function offline we
trained a policy so actually what we
tried was using exactly the same
representation and just taking the value
function which we'd learned and
basically using a soft max over that
value function to come up with the
policy so in particular what we did was
we said ok for each of the moves which
you could play in this situation let's
imagine that the patterns which would be
activated if you were to play those out
that move and then they could softmax
over all of the values that you would
reach and so we now have actually what
was quite a stronger policy trained in
this way much stronger than handcrafted
policies that were available before
we can ask how well does this policy do
when we use it so how can we use this
policy well the most obvious idea
perhaps is to insert this policy into
the search process and use it as a roll
out policy in other words whenever we
run this multicolored research we're
running one simulation whenever we reach
this kind of AB roll out phase of the of
the algorithm we run our roll out and
instead of picking actions the way we
were before we're going to use our
learned policy to insert this offline
policy here to pick the actions all the
way to the end of the game and you might
think that by using a much stronger
policy there that would end up with more
effective estimates of value in the
search tree one of the big surprises of
this paper that we had in 2007 was
actually this turned out not to be the
case and I think this was a surprise to
many of us at this time so surprisingly
having a much much stronger offline
policy did not lead to a more effective
roll out policy so in particular we had
this with this learned policy which had
been trained by reinforcement learning
and it was winning almost all of the
time against the hand crafted policy and
yet when we plugged it into the search
and we looked at the Monte Carlo values
which were being estimated in the search
tree the Monte Carlo values were
actually much less accurate and we
believe that this is because of the
diversity was being lost so when you
actually use reinforcement learning it
tends to find the greediest and best
action and there's no incentive for it
to maintain diversity and so actually in
future work and subsequent work people
tended to more use of supervised
learning which maintains diversity
simply because humans tend to have a
more diverse selection of moves and so
that representation maintains diversity
we also had some subsequent work with
reinforcement learning where we showed
that additional techniques were able to
address this paradox by actually
balancing the diversity more directly
and those techniques that we described
between the online knowledge part and
the offline put notes part was kind of
summarized in Mogo which has programmed
basically of build out of those elements
of Monte Carlo tree search press the
race plus some simple valid functions to
initialize a node in the tree and some
roll out with the custom policy and this
simple combination at the time was
giving a big boost in performance and
especially compared to the previous kind
of generation of programs we were which
were not using Monte Carlo tree search
and more as a better search there were a
huge improvement and another thing is
that it's also the first program that's
won a game against a professional so of
course it was nine by nine go which is
kind of one fourth of the board and it
was one game out of cyril but it was
something that was not thought a few
years before and so now if we go back to
the timeline right while we were showing
the traditional search programs and
their performance now what happens with
the Monte Carlo search program so those
were Monte Carlo search not with the
three part and from there I it was with
the three part and you see that
relatively early those nine curve and
the other interesting thing is that the
slope of the curve is actually better
and show no asymptotes yet and now the
question in 2007 was what is this line
how is it going to plateau very fast and
not reach master level even amateur
level or is it going to go like a
straight line or is it going to even
explode as more programs are going to
use those techniques and just as an
anecdote when we were like beginning in
this Monte Carlo tree search changes
with all those improvements there were a
lot of skepticism from motivational
approaches so actually Monte Carlo tree
search started in smaller boards and
started to win against some program but
always it was yes but it's not going to
be strong humans and then when you
started to be strong humans yes but
that's not the real game and then when
started to be the real game yes but it's
not going to be strong players and
that's what at this time yes it's it's
already beating traditional program but
is it going to meet and now you have to
give and we were guessing at this time
and actually we sit down with David and
we wrote some prediction or some deaths
I mean it was not really bad as we are
mostly agreeing but we wrote that in
beginning of 2007 we have proof of that
if you want and then we were trying to
see ok let's see now in the future and
because it's a test of time I think it's
interesting to show how much those tests
of time so the first bet was kind of
very short-term within six months one
program will beat the professional in
the smaller board 9.9 the second one was
within two years a program will reach
what's called a master level a tomato
like one then Ingo and finally the big
bet long-term but at that time ten years
one program would be undisputed world
champion within ten years so I'm not
going to spoil but that was the thing
and we see how it went and after this
2007 kind of Hira there have been a lot
of improvements of course and most of
the improvements were on the offline
policy and especially using better
features like better patterns better and
crusted features and also using
supervised human data to learn in
supervised ways of policy and we saw
stronger policy
another thing that changes how the
offline policy was used online so as a
roll out policy that the same as we've
discussed but as the offline policy was
also used to buy us the surgery so in in
the brief thing we are saying that we
use the offline value to initialize
nodes in Monte Carlo tree search but
here the idea is instead of doing that
when you have to choose which branch to
bro you can as well use your offline
policy to buy us a search and
concentrate too sir good moves and now
we extend the line because that nice
thing being in the future that the bad
prediction are easier to do so a 2007 is
here we were here and then the question
was is it going up or staying and
interestingly it went up almost as a
straight line by and more and more
program are using those techniques and
improving and up to basically 2011-12
well it certainly plateaued and here
note that we are a rigid master level is
still a matter level but is still
already strong program so at that time
with more compute and all those
improvements there were a lot of hope
that actually this is going to cross
professional but then suddenly it's
plateaued
so to bring us up to the present day I'm
now going to talk about the final piece
of the puzzle which is introducing deep
learning into the mix so in particular
when we started on the alphago project
we introduced a new form of offline
knowledge which was based on using deep
learning and in particular convolutional
neural networks so the idea was to have
a much more sophisticated representation
of knowledge of the game of go so the
way that that worked was that in each of
these continents we would take in a 19
by 19 input describing the black and
white stones in the position and that
would get fed through many many layers
giving rise to increasingly
sophisticated features which are
representing the board at a higher and
higher level and ultimately this
representation could be used as
knowledge of this offline knowledge in
various of the ways that we've already
seen and some new ways that are now
described so there were actually two
types of offline knowledge in alphago a
value network and a polity network so
the value network was actually a deep
neural network which took as input this
position passed it through many layers
12 layers in the original alphago and
many more and more recent versions and
finally output a single scalar value and
that value basically indicated whether
we thought that the current player would
win in this position do you think the
black is going to win or do we think the
white is going to win the second formal
knowledge that we used in alphago is the
policy network so the idea of the policy
network is again to take a position as
an input to the neural network pass it
through all these different layers but
this time to actually output a
probability map and that probability map
is basically saying how how much
preference alphago has to selecting a
particular move in this whole whole
board so in this particular example it
really likes to play this move I also
like to play some of these other moves
and it really isn't very keen on some of
those other moves and so these are the
two forms of offline knowledge that we
used in alphago but how are they trained
well we actually used a machine learning
pipeline that consisted of both
supervised learning and reinforcement
learning and the whole of these training
pipeline was when we introduced alphago
it was completely offline so if we start
with these human expert positions we
start off with an expert data set that
basically says what would a really
strong human player play in this
position and then we apply standard
supervised learning techniques to
basically train the policy network to
predict the move which was played by the
human expert in that Beach of those
positions and that gives rise to a very
nice representation of policy that's
able to predict are much better than
previous approaches what a human would
do in each of these positions but then
we want to go further and apply
reinforcement learning to this so what
we actually did was we took the policy
network and we got it to play against
itself thousands of games of self play
and we applied reinforcement learning
both to improve the policy network by
policy gradient techniques but also to
estimate now the value network so
specifically the value network is
trained so that basically what we want
to do is from each position we play a
game of self play of the policy network
against itself and we ask the value
network to predict who would win from
that game of self play do we think the
blackball win from this position or do
we think that white will win from this
position and this gives rise to a very
nice estimate of value in fact this was
the first time in the history of
computer go that we had a reasonable
estimator a kind of strong estimate of
really just from this scattering of
black and white stones who is going to
win in this position so now we've got
those two forms of offline knowledge how
did we combine them with search as we
combine them with the online knowledge
that we have in a in a in a Monte Carlo
tree search so we actually use two ideas
the first idea was to use the value
network to actually replace the
subsequent search tree which we have
previously had to do at each node of a
search tree at the nice leaf nodes so
you can think of this as much taking the
place of an evaluation function is in a
traditional game tree search like a
evaluation function in a chess program
now we have something where we reach
this this leaf node here and we simply
query alphago so who do you think will
win do you think black will win or do
you think white will win and instead of
having to do subsequent search we can
plug in that offline value and combine
that with the online values which are
being computed in the search and so you
can think of this in some way as if we
compare it to what was done before with
Monte Carlo tree search methods
previously we could think of it the
values that were being estimated as a
bit like crowdsourcing it was a bit like
asking 100 weak players to play games
against each other
these rollouts play games against each
other and then ask these hundred players
by crowdsourcing to estimate who is
going to win and if 70 out of the
hundred players actually won in their
games of self play then we we say well
we'll be the crowd source value estimate
would be 0.7 in contrast the new idea in
alphago is to replace those hundreds of
weak players in crowdsourcing with one
strong estimate and so the intuition was
that if you have one ask one strong
player who is going to win from this
position here that that estimate of that
strong player will actually be more
valuable than the crowd source estimate
of many weak players maybe if we did
find that to be the case so we can think
of this as the offline value really
replacing the role of rollouts or
augmenting the role that we had with
roll outs and replacing those online
values with something that was trained
offline the second idea in alphago was
actually to reduce the breadth of this
enormous search tree and so the way we
do that and was actually to bias the
search tree towards the most promising
branches so here we basically use this
powerful
policy network to recommend paths
through the search tree so from each
position we use this offline knowledge
to say actually it's going to be more
likely to lead to a good outcome if you
go this way rather than this way and
those recommendations basically ensure
that the search tree focuses on the best
regions of this enormous search base
so basically alphago combines these two
methods together reducing the depth with
the value Network and reducing the
breadth with the polity Network to
actually address the enormous search
space that we have in something like the
gamers go so when we put it all together
in alphago we actually achieved some
nice results so starting in 2015 we were
able to defeat the European champion
Soundwave by five games to zero the next
year we actually defeated the 18 time
world champion Lisa doll by four games
to one in Seoul and finally this year we
were able to defeat the world ranked
number one player cugir by three games
to zero so if we go
back to our timeline showing how
progress was made with traditional
search and then this take off that
Sylvan was explaining with Monte Carlo
search which eventually asymptotes it we
see that actually deep blending kind of
took up the slack and was able to come
in to the rescue just when we thought
that our bet was looking difficult this
deep learning really led to a
spectacular acceleration of performance
taking us beyond these amateur master
levels into the professional regime and
ultimately beyond human capabilities so
just to summarize so far in this talk
we've presented several different ways
to combine online and offline knowledge
together and we've seen that throughout
this timeline from 2007 to 2017 there
have been several different ways in
which these different types of knowledge
are being combined together so starting
in 2007 back with the original paper
what we saw was in the program Mogo we
actually combined together offline
values and online values in each node of
the search tree so specifically each
node of the search tree was actually
storing a value and that value combined
together Monte Carlo estimates that were
computed online from rollouts rave
estimates that were computed online by
generalizing across actions within those
rollouts and the offline value function
which was either estimated through
reinforcement learning or handcrafted
and these were combined together at
every node of the search tree to give a
much more effective estimate of value
which led to much stronger progress than
previous approaches to Monte Carlo tree
search in addition Mogo also used an
offline policy either trained by RL or
handcrafted in to actually give a more
effective rollout at the end of this
rollout stage of the tree search we then
move on to the intermediate stage
programs like crazy stone and then and
many other programs in the intervening
period augmented those ideas and also
introduced many other ideas we haven't
had time to explain and what they did is
was instead of focusing so much on value
they started focusing more on policy
they'll end an offline policy by
supervised learning using handcrafted
features
and that offline polity was used instead
of directly affecting the the values in
each node of the tree those offline
policies were used to influence the
decisions that were made from each node
of the search tree so this is basically
used to skew the UCT liked selection
rule towards things towards actions that
the policy believed was most likely to
be successful and in addition the
offline policy a simpler version of
faster version of the offline policy was
also used during the rollout phase
finally if we move on to alphago we see
a kind of return to something which was
more akin to traditional search the idea
of using an offline value function now
to actually something more like an
evaluation function itself so the idea
was that we trained this very powerful
offline value using a convolutional
neural network but instead of just
affecting that node in the search tree
the idea is this is treated like an
outcome that's actually backed up
through the entire path of the tree that
actually led to that position so instead
of just influencing that one node it
influences the entire structure of the
search tree and this turned out to be a
more powerful idea that led to more
effective results in practice in
addition the online value which is
combined with was based on Monte Carlo
outcomes by averaging over these values
but that we no longer found it helpful
to use the rave idea and finally we use
an offline policy again to influence the
action selection that was taken using
again a skewing of these UCT like
equation to actually prefer to pick
actions which the policy believed were
most successful so the nature so there
were two things which changed first of
all the nature of the offline knowledge
was much more powerful due to deep
learning but in addition there was also
this more effective way to combine
online and offline knowledge together
and now by
prediction so now that you've seen
everything you should be able to scroll
three out of three out of this exam
so the first prediction was can we
defeat a professional in 999 in a short
term and as we discuss mojo actually in
June 2007 was winning one game in an
exhibition match then the second thing
is can we achieve a master level at a
meta level within two years and actually
it happened in two ways so first in a
weak way well no go on
one tournament at this level and in a
more consistent way by then in 2009
which still fits to our the two years
timeframe and was reaching one time
consistently and then finally you all
know about the world champion and as we
say in French
you'll never better serve them by
yourself and they've either to go to the
rescue to our prediction so just to
finish I really wants to say thank you
to the organizers of ICML for this nice
award and very unexpected that we really
appreciate it and thank you again and
I'm happy to take questions now